en el último vídeo teníamos a [ __ ]
empezando un fondo mutuo de inversión
abierta
y que era administrado por [ __ ] inc los
fondos mutualistas normalmente tienen
nombres grandiosos quizás llamaron a
este el fondo saturno y si hay un fondo
saturno por ahí solo elegía el nombre al
azar no estoy diciendo que en serio seas
tú ni nada por el estilo digo a lo mejor
le puede haber llamado el fondo galileo
el punto es que es un nombre rimbombante
acá muy muy muy elevado no solo inventé
el nombre al azar pero es administrado
por picking que llamamos esto un fondo
de inversión abierta porque en cualquier
momento alguien de los que tenían una
acción o una unidad en el fondo pueden
reclamar el dinero de vuelta y aquí pido
la compañía administradora diría si
quieres tus 180 dólares de vuelta lo
compraremos ok solo es más te daremos
280 dólares devuelves la acción y luego
cancelamos la acción y si cualquiera
quiere sumarse al fondo si quieren
invertir la corporación puede crear
nuevas acciones y emitirlo a la gente
vendérselo a la gente y su dinero iría a
la reserva común y la compañía
administradora tomaría cuotas de ello
y quizás eso te ha hecho preguntarte si
esto es un fondo de inversión abierta
qué es un fondo de inversión cerrada o
al menos existen y de hecho si de eso es
de lo que voy a hablar aquí fondos de
inversión cerrada y los fondos de
inversión cerrada en cierto nivel son
más simples lo que ocurre en un fondo de
inversión cerrada es que todos los
inversionistas son esencialmente o
supongo que puedes decir que la
estructura de acciones está cerrada
desde el inicio así que pitt y si [ __ ]
quisiera empezar su fondo mutuo de
inversión cerrada tendría que nuevamente
registrarse anunciarla les diría a todos
soy [ __ ] soy un gran inversionista aquí
está mi trayectoria y después él
simplemente debería tener un buen
convencimiento y digamos que logra
hallar a 20 inversionistas ok aquí no va
a contarlos digamos que hay 20 partes
aquí el obtiene 20 personas así que
digamos que cada uno da 100 dólares a si
es capaz de juntar dos mil dólares 20
veces 100 dólares verdad así es capaz de
juntar dos mil dólares y una vez que eso
ocurre el fondo se cierra
y va a ser su mejor esfuerzo para
administrar esto así que administrará
esto y aún tendrá una cuota por ello
okay quizás del 1% pero lo que es
fundamentalmente diferente aquí que
aunque puede anunciar el fondo bueno no
tiene que hacerlo más porque no puede
conseguir nuevos inversionistas y esta
es la principal diferencia un fondo de
inversión abierta en cualquier momento o
quizás debería decir al final de las
operaciones al final del día ellos
pueden ganar o perder inversionistas así
que es un incentivo para un fondo el de
estar constantemente anunciarse porque
el administrador quiere administrar más
y más dinero y así ganar más por la
cuota de administración aquí estos los
del fondo de inversión cerrada sólo se
anuncian al inicio entonces ya que
conseguimos estos 20 inversionistas ya
no puede crear más acciones o cancelar
ni una sola acción pero lo que puede
ocurrir así que digas bueno en un fondo
cómo es que estas personas digamos
digamos que tú tienes una acción estadía
que sale qué pasa si tú quieres y si
necesitas comprar una casa o si le debes
dinero a alguien
así que quieres obtener el valor de tu
acción de vuelta y la respuesta con un
fondo de inversión cerrada es que
entonces irías a vender tu acción a
alguien más esta está de aquí la puedes
comerciar la puedes comerciar y la
puedes comerciar justo como comerciar
las acciones de una empresa grande de
una acción de ibm la mayoría de las
veces solo lo compras o vendes de
alguien más no estás negociando con la
compañía ibm estás comerciando con el
mercado secundario no estás lidiando con
la corporación actual así que es ahí en
donde el inversionista obtiene su
liquidez y cuando decimos liquidez les
permite convertirlo en efectivo porque
pueden comerciar lo así que la gran
diferencia fondos de inversión abierta
cuando un inversionista quiere su dinero
de vuelta tiene que lidiar con el fondo
mismo ok
tiene que lidear con el fondo el fondo
comprar a su acción de vuelta y si
alguien quiere invertir en un fondo el
fondo les vende la acción así que
siempre están lidiando con el fondo en
el caso de la inversión cerrada una vez
que el fondo es creado su reserva se
cierra y si alguien quiere comprar o
vender tiene que ocurrir en el mercado
secundario así que
se van comprando por fuera y no están
lidiando con la empresa la desventaja
del administrador es que todo esto es
mucho menos flexible en términos de
crecimiento verdad la ventaja es que el
administrador del fondo no tiene que
guardar efectivo volando en caso de que
los propietarios de acciones que han
redimirse en el fondo de inversión
abierta vimos que el administrador debe
tener cierto efectivo en caso de que uno
de los inversionistas quiera su dinero
de vuelta aquí sabe que nadie puede
tener su dinero de vuelta así que puede
invertir como le parezca justo